نذير من الأشياء التي يجب أن تأتي على الطريق المؤدية
إلى
مدينة تشانسك التي كانت في خط النار
لأشهر
، قبو المدرسة يخدم كمأوى
لعشرات السكان ،
الجميع في الخارج الآن ، كما تقول ،
لأنه مظلمة للغاية ويصعب التنفس
هنا
في الخارج ينتظرون بينما يطبخون الحساء فوق
النار
، لا يوجد غاز ، ولا قوة ، ولا
يخبرني الماء أنه ليس لدينا أي شيء ، لقد
تعبت من العمر
مرعوبًا ،
وأنا وحدي أقول ماشا البالغة من العمر 82 عامًا ،
ساقي متعبة ، لا يمكنني الذهاب إلى أي مكان
طاحونة لطيفة
لقد اعتقدنا أن الأمر سيهدأ ، لكن
الأمر يزداد سوءًا وأسوأ ، تقول إنني
لا أستطيع تحمل هذه الأصوات بعد الآن
ناتاليا ، النوافذ في منزلي
محطمة ، تقول إن هناك حفرة ضخمة بجوار
منزلي ، إنها نهاية
العالم المشمس  يتناقض الطقس مع ما أصبح
وجودًا بعد نهاية العالم ،
يصطف السكان للحصول على المياه غير المفلترة
حتى يتمكنوا من غسل ودفق المراحيض
لمدة أربعة أشهر تقريبًا من الحرب مع عدم وجود نهاية في
الأفق.
كان من المفترض أن يأتوا إلى هنا
مرة واحدة على الأقل
عبر النهر ، حيث احتدم
القتال في الشوارع المتوحشة في سيفيروس
ليس بالقرب من الجبهة ، بل في المقدمة
عند الساعة الثالثة بعد الظهر ،
ضربت الطائرات الروسية هذا
المبنى الذي كان هذا المبنى بمثابة مأوى  بالنسبة
للأشخاص
الثلاثة الذين قُتلوا ، ويظهر حقًا
أنه لا يوجد مكان في ليسي
تشانسك آمن ،
حيث كانت يودميلو في ذلك المبنى الذي
أصيب زوجها في الغارة
بالأمس ، وقد سُحق تحت
الأنقاض ، وتقول
إنها لا تستطيع فعل شيء سوى البكاء لأنها
تنتظر  اركب لرؤيته في مستشفى
بن ويدمان